The worldview three
satellite passing over
southern Japan spies
something in the forest
below.
This report shows that
Japanese scientists were
running an experiment to
see how a space affects
tree growth. So what
they did was plant ten
concentric rings of
trees.
They had the same amount
of trees in each ring.
So when you were closer
to the center, of course
they were closer to each
other.
In a feat of superhuman
scientific endurance.
Over the next half
century, botanists
painstakingly monitor
how each ring of trees
develops.
And as you get out from
that center, they get
more spaced, more room
for sunlight and more
room for their roots to
grow and get water.
So of course, they grew
taller.
While the scientific
importance of this
strange experiment may
be debatable, its impact
from space is hard to
deny.